so donald trump continues to deny that
he had
many strokes and again this is only
raising more questions because
the upcoming book from michael schmidt
um
from the new york times doesn't allege
trump had
strokes and trump continuing to bring it
up is starting to put more attention on
it
than there would be uh otherwise and the
back story of course
is that michael schmidt's book claims
that when donald trump abruptly went to
walter reed hospital in 2019 for that
unscheduled visit
that it was some kind of urgent medical
situation he doesn't say what kind it
was
but he does say that mike pence was put
on notice be prepared
to take over as president because donald
trump
may need to go under anesthesia trump
has brought up this issue of many
strokes
which is not a claim that's actually
made in the book trump introduces the
idea of strokes in a tweet last week
where he said quote it never ends now
they are trying to say that your
favorite president me
went to walter reed medical center
having suffered a series of mini strokes
never happened to this candidate fake
news
perhaps they're referring to another
candidate from another party
then trump brings it up again during
this latrobe pennsylvania
corona rally which i covered last week
trump spent
several minutes on this again telling
this totally implausible story
that he said hey you know what let's go
over to walter reed
last minute to get a jump on next year's
physical it was never believable but
again
trump brings up mini strokes take a look
at this
[Applause]
no but the new one is you know i went
for a physical the doctor said to me sir
would you like to go over to walter reed
it's incredible by the way
the job they do on people that have been
just really hurt
are heroes and the job they do is
incredible but
sir would you like to go over and do a
physical
you have some time you know why i had
time some deal oh it was
china i decided not to see china
because they didn't like the way they
were doing business okay does that make
sense
so the doctor white house doctor highly
respected
sean sean connolly sir would you like to
go over and do your physical or do a
piece of it or finish it or whatever it
was but do a physic
i said i don't know i'm not in love with
the idea well let's
if you do it we don't have to do it so
okay let's go come on
so we went way one and we're driving now
you have to understand there are like
you know 100 cars you see what happens
here it's like the plane times
50. so the cars are driving all over
it's about a 20 minute drive
and we get to the hospital i get out i
was there probably for an hour and a
half two hours
and then yesterday i read that i had
strokes
cnn fake news cnn right there
[Applause]
now it's true mini strokes they called
them
i don't know what a mini stroke is but
it's not good
and there could be a day and donald
admit i said hey it happens to all of us
right
except these young ones it's never going
to happen to them they're not looking at
that but you know what happens
but nothing happened so i went in i did
that part of the physical the end result
was he's very healthy
they're very unhappy when they heard
that result so
first first of all imagine that this is
the behavior
of an american president just let let
that sink in for a second
but going further than that you know
sometimes people will write to me
they'll say david why do you keep making
a big deal out of this
totally outrageous behavior given that
it's so common and we've become so used
to it
that's exactly why we should not be used
to it
and we cannot allow this type of
insanity to be normalized that's why i
keep talking about it
to try to fight the normalization to get
back to the main topic
this is crazy because trump keeps
bringing up how he didn't have strokes
nobody alleged that he had strokes now i
know it's been speculated
by random people but the allegations
in the book that trump is responding to
don't mention strokes
it's sort of like when trump started to
bizarrely focus in on acing his
cognitive test
which is a test that is not difficult
and it's just meant to screen out
serious dementia trump calling it a
difficult test
it's wild stuff it is unforced errors
trump talking about he and biden should
take drug
tests before debates because maybe biden
took something before his debate with
bernie
the speculation of course is that it's
trump who sometimes seems all hopped up
with the dilated pupils and the sweating
it's constant projection of this kind
and
it's now become almost like we're headed
to some kind of boxing match
with a weigh-in anti-doping screenings
more so than we are presidential debates
uh as far as the strokes go why does
trump keep talking about it
doesn't this just raise the suspicion
even more that he's constantly now
talking about strokes
nobody claimed that he had very very
strange stuff and
listen my position is the following i
don't know what happened to trump on
that day
what i do know is that the story of
saying hey you know what
let's right now like right now let's
drive over to walter reed to get a jump
on my physical for next year
and spend hours there it doesn't make
sense
it doesn't pass the sniff test that's
what i can tell you
the fact that trump keeps mentioning
strokes is certainly
weird if not concerning one of our
sponsors today
is hydrant and they are giving my
audience 25
off your first order this has been a
game changer for me this is a refreshing
electrolyte powder that you mix directly
into your water
to rehydrate your body because it is
packed
with the four essential electrolytes
that your body needs the most
that's sodium potassium magnesium and
zinc
and because of how hydrant is formulated
it's an efficient way
of getting yourself rehydrated and it
tastes
awesome there's a variety of flavors i
have blood orange which i love
you can also get grapefruit and lime a
lot of us don't even realize when we're
dehydrated a lot of the time
and it's become a really a great part of
my daily routine
if i'm under hydrated i'm affected
physically
i'm affected mentally and i think you
never
fully understand this until you use
hydrant for the first time
i get a great a boost of energy when i'm
properly hydrated if i've been
dehydrated
they also have a version with caffeine
which i love
if and when that's what i'm looking for
everyone in my audience gets twenty five
percent off your first order
when you go to drink hydrant dot com
slash
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video